[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOW: I'm Francis Low.
And let me welcome
you here tonight.
And let me start by
calling on Mr. Greg
Mitchell of the Student
Disarmament Study Group,
who would like to
make an announcement.
Mr. Mitchell--
MITCHELL: On behalf of the
MIT Students Disarmament Study
Group, I'd like to
bring to your attention
a project we've been
working on for quite a
while is within hours
of reaching fruition.
If you're interested in
speaking with your congressman
about arms race issues,
now's your chance.
Massachusetts students,
staff, and faculty
will be joining with thousands
from across the nation
tomorrow for a day of
lobbying in Washington, DC.
Buses will be leaving MIT
at 11:00 PM this evening.
After a day at
the capital, we'll
arrive back in Boston
early Friday morning.
The cost us $30.
All the appointments
have been made
with senators, and
representatives,
and their aides for all
the states in our nation.
If you're interested,
please see us
right outside the lecture
hall after this evening's
activities.
And after that,
there'll be a reception
for Massachusetts lobbyists in
room 407 of the Student Center.
The trip should
be quite exciting
and a worthwhile
experience for all.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: Let me welcome you again.
My name hasn't changed.
So I welcome you to this
year's Compton Lecture.
Tonight we mark the 40th
year since the explosion
of the first nuclear device
in the New Mexican desert.
11 present and
retired MIT professors
were involved in that
effort at Los Alamos
that culminated in that event.
Hence, the title of today's
set of talks and things
happening 40 years after
Los Alamos MIT and the bomb.
Eight of those MIT faculty
members are here tonight.
I would also hope
to see in that title
a reflection of the commitment
of so many members of my team's
community to doing something
about the situation in which we
in the world find ourselves.
These Los Alamos veterans
who are here tonight
have participated, in
lesser or greater degree,
many with great devotion
in that activity.
They have worked
throughout these 40 years
to contain the effects of
their terrible invention.
Their work made war obsolete,
but unfortunately it
did not make war impossible.
The existence of nuclear weapons
poses the greatest threat
since Nemesis to the
survival of life on Earth.
And if not life
on Earth, at least
the survival of
our civilization,
civilization as we know it.
I hope that the
meeting tonight will
help us think fruitfully and
usefully about what we can do
about these terrible questions.
I have to tell you--
I'm sorry to have to tell
you that Joe Wiesner will
be unable to join us.
Mrs. Wiesner is in the hospital.
It's not life threatening.
But she is confined-- she
is for the moment confined,
leaving the hospital
today in Florida.
And he had to be with her.
And he sends his best
wishes and regrets.
So we will hear tonight from the
two others scheduled speakers.
After their talk,
we are also honored
to have with us
tonight Mr. Bajpai, who
is the ambassador from
India to Washington.
After their talk, I will
ask him for a few comments.
And after that, we will open the
meeting to general discussion.
The two speakers are
both old friends of mine
and of many of us here.
I can't imagine two
different people.
But when I think of how
I should introduce them--
I have not been given
a prepared vita--
I mean, actually their vitas are
so long and so distinguished,
that one couldn't do
much with it anyway.
But as I thought about what
I want to say about them,
the same things come
to mind, although they
are extraordinarily
different people,
They are both physicists.
They are both
distinguished physicists.
They are MIT
Institute professors.
They are incredibly
learned, humane, humanist,
two wonderful people.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
And, of course,
after they've talked,
you'll tell the difference.
And I have no titles.
They'll give you
their own titles.
The first then is
Victor Weisskopf--
Viki--
[APPLAUSE]
WEISSKOPF: My friends, I
don't have a special title.
40 years after, thoughts
inspired by those 40 years.
40 years ago, in the early
morning hours of July 16,
a truck driver in
New Mexico reported
that he saw the sun
about to rise at 4:00 AM.
But then the sun decided
it was too early,
and went back again, and
came up an hour earlier--
an hour later.
And that was, of course,
the historic event
of the first man-made atomic
explosion, which some of you
saw this afternoon in the movie.
I have witnessed this event,
actually, roughly at the same--
actually, exactly at
the same place as Phil.
I remember we both
were sitting together.
The description we
got from the army
was that we should lie
down with our stomachs--
on our stomachs, with our
heads away from the explosion.
Of course, we wouldn't
dream to do that,
because we wanted to
see what's going on.
So after the generals who
were there had put themselves
into that position--
[LAUGHTER]
Phil and I, and many others
there, took our dark glasses--
we figured out
that the intensity
should be roughly 20 midday
suns at that distance,
and looked at it, and tried to
measure the size to estimate
the efficiency and so on.
It was, indeed, an
incredible sight
and an awesome experience, which
hardly is desirable in words.
Imagine the landscape lit up 20
times stronger than sunlight.
And even at that distance, we
felt an intense blast of heat
and a roaring thunder after
three quarters of a minute.
And we saw this steadily
ascending fireball, made
a brilliant hemisphere,
up into a sphere,
becoming slowly
white, yellow, orange,
surrounded by this blue halo.
And then finally, assuming
the well-known mushroom shape.
And then the sun
actually went up
and illuminated the whole
thing with the red sunlight.
Suddenly a credible impression
that filled all of us
with awe, with pride
of unique achievement,
and suddenly with misgivings
about the future of mankind.
A few weeks after
that trial, two bombs
were thrown over
two cities in Japan.
Whatever one may
think about the wisdom
of the American
use of the bombs,
it did end the murderous war.
And most probably saved
many hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of
people, on both sides.
It may have saved many
more than it has destroyed.
We meant so well.
And we served our country.
And we thought that
such powerful weapons
would make wars impossible.
And we hoped very much
that this whole thing
would lead to an international
administration of every thing
atomic or nuclear
power in weapons.
And then it would be
an end of the old--
the age-old human custom of
organized mutual mass murder.
We went out and gave talks
to civic organizations,
to the people in Santa Fe,
and other cities nearby.
And I remember I was quoting
John Donne at that time--
no man is an island
entirely for himself.
Every man is a piece of the
continent, a part of the main.
Never ask for whom the bell
tolls, it tolls for thee.
And what we meant is that
this will bring, finally,
mankind together.
Well, we were naive and wrong.
We should have known better.
True enough, the
existence of the bomb
has kept peace for the
last 40 years, at least,
between the big powers.
This is an unusually
long period.
But these powers have
found only one way
to maintain the
state of affairs,
to indulge in an
ever-increasing arms race.
More and more weapons were made.
And at this moment
in history, I do
believe that we are
on a collision course.
The nuclear armaments
go ahead, accelerated.
New types of weapons
are introduced.
Technical innovations that make
the weapons more efficient,
but any kind of arms control
more difficult. [INAUDIBLE]
the consequences of a potential
military conflict become
increasingly more [INAUDIBLE]
with a total explosive power
6,000 times more
than all the bombs
that were exploded
during the World War I.
Now this, to my mind, when only
a 50th perhaps is necessary,
complete [INAUDIBLE] this case
of collective mental disease
that has gripped humanity.
And I think it will be seen
as such in 30-40 years,
if we survive.
And all that came from us,
from our work at Los Alamos
and other of these laboratories.
It came from our brain
child, from our achievements
40 years ago.
Many statesmen and a
good part of the public
is today aware of the
fact that the actual use
of even a small part of all
this would be the greatest
catastrophe of mankind.
But being aware is not enough.
We must recognize why
is it that we go on
and increase the probability
of the danger over nuclear war.
Why must that threat, which
supposedly keeps peace and did
keep peace, why must this threat
be multiplied all the time
by a steadily increasing factor?
Why cannot people in governments
get their heads together
and recognize--
and say, enough is
enough and recognize
the danger of all this?
I believe that one
of the main reasons
is that there are
many kinds of fear.
There is, for example, the
fear of a first strike.
Both sides are afraid that
the other side [INAUDIBLE]
and particularly the land based
missiles before retaliation.
Now that fear is in many
ways more irrational,
because the US has more
than half of its missiles
in submarines, which are,
at least for a good time,
impossible to exactly locate,
so they cannot be destroyed,
most of them, at least.
And the Russians
have about a quarter
of their missiles in submarines.
And given the destructive
power, if even one submarine--
it is plain that a
first strike just
could not disarm an adversary.
Another fear is the fear to
be weaker than the other side.
See, up to the mid
-70s, the United States
had considerably more
weapons, nuclear weapons,
than the Soviet Union.
Although the latter
had even at that time
enough weapons to destroy us.
But since then, the Soviet Union
has reached a sort of equality
with us and that has people
very uneasy, to say the least.
But let me say, this increase
of the Russian nuclear weapons,
which happened in the second
part of the '70s and beginning
of the '80s is has been preceded
by a very strong increase
of the United States
from about 2,000 to 8,000
at strategic points.
So we are now roughly
at the same level.
Ironically, just that
approximate parity
adds a lot to the
present difficulties
and to the arms race.
Why?
Because you never know.
And there's a lot of secrecy,
particularly on the other side.
And therefore, you [INAUDIBLE]
worst, and to think
there are more weapons there.
And therefore, has to build
more and build them up.
This is one of the
driving forces, of course,
of the arms race.
The second-- the
third fear, actually,
is of being out distanced--
out distanced in a
certain type of weapon.
For example, the Russians
have actually more land based
and we have more
submarine weapons.
So we think we have to have
the same number of land based
missiles.
And the Russians have those
big land based missiles.
And that is one reason why
people want to build the MX.
So actually, we're
going to build the MX.
And the Soviet Union, of
course, on the other side,
is going to build
submarines, because they
have fewer than we are.
This is, again, and
mechanism for escalation.
A third fear-- or this
is now the fourth fear,
comes from a perceived or
an actual aggressive policy
of the opponent.
Both sides believe
that the other side
is bent on aggression,
whereas they, themselves,
act purely defensively.
Of course, the US
definitely says
that what happened
in Afghanistan
is an aggressive act,
or in Southeast Asia.
But this is seen by the other
side as a defense effect,
to ensure the security of their
borders, where in Vietnam,
the Russians to establish
a counterbalance
to the influence of China.
Conversely, the US has a
lot of defensive actions
to prevent the spread
of communist influence,
for example in Central
America, in the Middle East.
And these are
perceived, of course,
by the Soviet
Union as an attempt
to build up Western
influence wherever possible.
And the recent Star War plans
is a particular good example.
It is perceived by
the Soviet Union
as a preparation
for first strike,
because then we can
have a first strike
and at least the
consequences of retaliation
will be diminished, so that you
can perhaps supposedly support
them, which I don't believe,
but perhaps they believe.
So each military
and political action
abroad can be interpreted
as aggressive or defensive
by one side or the other.
And during a political
crisis, of course,
such misrepresentations
are extremely dangerous.
The lack of understanding
comes, of course,
from a very completely
different system, social system,
political system.
We are afraid of the
authoritarian regime of world
communism, the lack of
elementary human rights
on the other side, the
treatment of minorities,
the suppression of
freedom in the satellites
and the homeland.
That arouses fears
in the United States.
And vise-versa, the ideology
of capitalist free enterprise,
the human rights activities,
the virulent anti-communism,
strong support of right wing
dictators, and lately the talk
about liberating the world
from the evils of communism,
necessarily arouses fear
in the Soviet Union,
and not only in the
leading circles.
Now, in order to
understand a little more,
I think that's a very
important thing, the fears
and the subsequent
actions of our adversary,
you must consider the
present situation.
Let me express it this way.
There are four large
power complexes--
China, the Soviet Union,
Western Europe, United States.
Three of them have one enemy--
or let me adversary--
the Soviet Union.
One of them, the Soviet Union,
has four-- namely the three
others and its own population.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, it's no laughing
matter for them.
And this explains
a lot of actions.
For example, one of the
reasons-- certainly one
of the reasons of the
large conventional forces
in Soviet Union is the fear
of revolts in Eastern Europe.
The overly large number
of Soviet SS 20 missiles
is probably meant to deter
the Western aid for revolts,
possible revolts
in Eastern Europe,
and to support incipient
anti-Soviet governments.
Now, the fact that
the West never
has supported such
movements does not
allay their fears that they
may do it in the future.
Now, these fears are important,
but they are not the only cause
of the armaments race.
I am coming now to another
very dangerous and important--
more and more important
cause of the armaments race.
And that is the
increasing momentum
of the military machine.
Years of intense developments,
and buildup of weapons,
of means of delivery,
of new methods
to improve the accuracy, they've
established and interwoven
system of vested interests, of
ambitious and dedicated groups
unwilling to give up their
successful activities, not
only, or maybe not
even very much,
because of financial interests.
Although, I'm sure
this plays a role.
But also, because of
a natural commitment
to pursue a difficult
task, just when
it's about to yield
more and better results.
No doubt most participants
believe that they will--
that what they do will enhance
the security of the United
States or the Soviet Union.
But it is probably not so.
How can an armaments
race increase security?
I remember this very
well from personal
experience in Los Alamos.
I think this afternoon there
was a little discussion,
but I will still mention it now.
Namely, in Los Alamos, we all--
most of us, like myself,
and many of my friends,
went to Los Alamos only
because we were afraid
that Hitler will make the bomb.
Still, when the bomb--
when Hitler was defeated, just
about 40 years ago in May,
there wasn't even
discussion of quitting.
We just worked on
because we had also
this technological
momentum, that--
Oppenheimer uses
this uncanny term,
a technically sweet project.
That's the danger.
Of course, the same
danger of this momentum
is also in our
preparations on both sides,
a preparation to engage
in a nuclear war.
Strategies and
tactics are developed.
An escalating
search for military
targets to be hit in case.
And the more such
targets are found,
the more bombs have to
be deployed to hit them.
Should the deterrents
fail, so goes the argument,
nuclear war may be
come and we must
be prepared to prevail
in a limited nuclear war.
But, of course, a nuclear
war very probably cannot be
limited.
The losing side will
be forced to escalate.
Two archers facing one
another, saying the tighter I
draw the bow, the
safer I become.
Unfortunately, also
these preparations
are fueled by
their own momentum.
The more developments going
on, the more possibilities
of attacks are found, as I said.
The more pressures
develop for deployment.
And such preparations made
a certain sense in the past,
when war was really acceptable
as the last assault for which
we must be well prepared.
In my hometown, in Vienna,
there is a monument.
And it says on the
monument, [SPEAKING LATIN]
For those who don't
know Latin, it
means when you wish for
peace, prepare for war.
Today's that slogan can
no longer be applied.
To prepare for nuclear war is
to prepare for mutual suicide.
So the arms race is the
product of irrational fears
felt by both contending powers.
And there is a
self-perpetuating mechanism
that creates its own momentum
and increases the fears,
and draws all the activities
into its whirlpool.
And this is why the present
confrontation is so dangerous.
This is the first
part of my talk.
Now, I would like to
use the rest of the time
to those thoughts that must
come to people who are involved
with these questions.
What have we learned
now from what
happened in the last 40 years?
And how can we see
a hopeful future?
Which I do--
I don't believe-- at
least I feel in my bones
that we won't be all destroyed.
But only if we do
something about it.
Now, the last four decades have
taught us one important lesson.
Negotiations to reduce the
level of nuclear weapons
have very little
chance of success
in the prevailing atmosphere
of confrontation, distrust,
and increasingly offensive and
defensive weapon developments.
To the contrary,
there is a danger
of the erosion of even
those few treaties that
did slow down the armaments
race, like SALT I and SALT II.
Perhaps, I should
like to make a remark.
SALT I has an interesting
part, which many of you know,
namely the ABM
Treaty, which says
that you are not supposed
to defend yourself
against strategic missiles.
So quite so, you are
allowed to have one or two
establishments for that.
Actually, the United States
has not used it at all
and the Russians
have one, Moscow.
Now, this was a very
difficult development.
And I remember at
that time, I was
active in the Pugwash movement.
From '64-- that treaty was
concluded in the '70s--
'72.
From '64 on, we tried to talk
with the Russian scientists
to tell them that such defenses
are dangerous, because all they
will do is to increase the
number of offensive warheads,
so that an equilibrium,
so-called equilibrium is
established.
It was difficult to
convince the Russians.
Indeed, the Russian scientists
used the same arguments
which you hear today from
our government-- defense
obviously is good, how
can defense be bad?
We must defend ourselves.
And it took us many years,
but we succeeded, not
only to convince the scientists,
our government, at that time,
was also of that opinion.
And the scientists that
came to Pugwash, of course,
had very strong connections
with their government,
or they wouldn't be allowed
to come out to the West.
And they were able to convince
their government really
to sign that treaty,
which to some extent
has reduced the speed
of the armaments race,
though it didn't turn it around.
But the interesting thing,
I tell this only because
of the application of today.
Today the situation
seems to be reversed.
The same group of scientists
that convinced, at that time
the Russian scientists, that
defense, that kind of defense
against missiles will only
increase the armaments race,
we are not successful in
convincing our government,
our present government of this.
And vise versa,
the Russians now,
who we had a hard time
to convince, now say
exactly that idea and
repeat it, and probably
with good justification.
Well, this is just
to say that there
were certain efforts already
before, during these 40 years.
But there is now a chance
that all these treaties--
I wrote it-- for example, the
Star War project, of course,
would, if it actually goes into
the testing and development
phase, would be a
breach of the ABF
Treaty, which has saved us so
far from too much development.
Is there a chance that we can
arrive at a different attitude?
Evidently, we must.
There are compelling reasons.
And that is sort of
clear to everybody.
And their main point is
that nuclear weapons must
be regarded not
as weapons of war,
but their only purpose
is to deter their use
by the other side.
And for this, of course, we
have much fewer than we have
at present.
Now, how can we
change those causes
which I've analyzed
before, limiting
mutual fears and the driving
forces of increasing armament
efforts?
Well, we must be aware
that the present situation,
the present confrontational
of the situation,
inducing fear in the opponent
is against one's own interest.
It only escalates
the armaments race.
Fear, of course, is
not an objective fact,
like the number of warheads.
It arises from interpretation
or misinterpretations
of statements and actions
by the other side.
Now, what could be ways to
reduce fears and distrust.
I think an
indispensable first step
is an awareness of the problem.
For example, every statement
and every action on both sides
should be examined with the
view as to how will it be
interpreted on the other side.
Will it increase or reduce
the fear and distrust?
Obviously, you can
easily see examples
that increase the fear.
The deployment of
MX, the deployment
of the Trident II
submarines that
are accurate enough
to hit their missiles,
on our side, increase fear.
The great number,
the heavy SS18s
and the recent preparations
for deployments
of mobile missiles by the
Soviet Union increases the fear.
Of course, SS20 in Europe also.
Well, how can we deal
with those fears?
For example, how can we deal
with the fear of superiority?
Let's be sure, today both
sides, the East and the West
maintain that opponent
is militarily stronger.
You can read this
in our paper and you
can read it in their papers.
As remarked before,
it is not so much
the reality that counts,
but the perception.
Therefore, we must not only
strive to maintain an offensive
and defensive parity, because
if we try to be superior,
we only accelerate
the arms race,
because evidently they cannot
allow us to be superior.
Perhaps I should search
your one little remark.
One could say, aha, we're are
now technologically so far
ahead that we can become
superior and they cannot follow
us.
That would be the most dangerous
situation, because then they
would become--
they would fear that we will use
our superiority for blackmail,
that they have to give
in here and there.
That's probably
also the rationale
of those people who are
in favor of superiority.
But then they become irrational.
And governments become
very easily irrational.
And they will put
on the wall and they
will react in some way,
which induces a war.
Now, therefore, we must be sure
that both the East and the West
have also the perception
of being on parity.
That means one of the
most important things
is to have some
negotiations that
have the aim to make it clear,
to discuss how is parity meant.
We must put ourselves a
the little in their shoes
to understand it.
And we rarely do this.
I'll give you an example.
The present dispute over the
number of intermediate range
missiles in Europe.
The Soviets-- well,
we say we have
to put all these missiles
into European countries
because they have 10 times more
missiles, intermediate missiles
then we have, the SS20.
But of course, the Soviets
count the French and British
missiles, and find then that
both sides are about equal.
Now, we leave them out.
Imagine, for example--
now here, one
has to use the mirror
argument and put oneself
in the other's position.
Imagine, for example,
if they would not
count missiles they have
put into Hungary, or Poland,
or Cuba as missiles against us.
I mean, one has to have the
most primitive understanding
for the problem.
So there should be bilateral
discussion, or maybe
multilateral discussions,
because the Allied countries
on both sides are very
much interested in this.
They don't want
to be unprotected
witness in the
defensive build up
or launching pads in
an offensive build up.
Another thing is,
in order to get down
the fear of aggression.
And we must have a
better understanding
of their motivations
of their actions.
Here, the national body
for crisis management
would, of course, be
just an important step.
That body would discuss
actual or potentially expected
political and military events.
There already exist
such a bilateral body--
the standing
Consultative Commission,
that deals with supposed or real
infractions of the treaties,
and it has been very useful
in the past to smooth--
to get difficulties
out of the way.
Nowadays, when so-called
perceived infractions are right
away widely publicized,
and so the Commission
is no longer so effective.
But there is a
reason that we should
have as similar, of
course, much harder task,
of international
monitor, or maybe later
on, multilateral body that
discusses possible crisis.
Now, there are obviously
military measures that
could be taken to reduce fears.
We could, for example,
reduce our potential,
our strategic
potential by 10% or 20%
without weakening our position.
In particularly, we could reduce
first strike capabilities,
because we can't
use them anyway.
And the [INAUDIBLE] of never
using nuclear weapons first,
that would be also a
very important thing,
because a declaration
not to commit suicide
shouldn't be so difficult.
Of course, the Western
Europeans always think,
and they reason, with
some justification,
that the nuclear
deterrence is important
against a conventional attack.
But this reasoning is based upon
a very questionable assumption,
namely that a suicide threat
is an effective deterrent.
So these are problems
which we have to attack.
Now, one trivial case.
And that is that there are
8,000 small nuclear weapons,
so-called battlefield
weapons, around in Europe.
And of course, both sides,
roughly this number.
And those make really no
sense at all on the countries.
They're extremely dangerous.
By the way, they
aren't that small.
There are some of them that
are as big as the Hiroshima
explosions, some of you
have seen this afternoon.
There is a real good chance
of a successful negotiation
on that, because actually,
the US has already reduced
them unilaterally somewhat.
And it's obviously
an advantage to have
a higher threshold
against the outbreak
of a nuclear conflagration.
But these are all
smaller measures.
What is necessary,
and certainly,
what the last 40
years have shown then
is to reduce tension by other
and more effective methods.
We need a deeper
change of attitude
from this paranoid distrust.
[INAUDIBLE] is--
the US and the SU--
I like the symmetry
in the abbreviations--
are not enemies,
they're adversaries.
They have one common enemy
and that is nuclear war.
And they have many
common interests, apart
from escaping mutual
nuclear annihilation.
I'd like to talk a
little about that,
because this is important.
Because to work together
on other dangers
is helpful for
mutual understanding.
The world is, for example,
threatened by the increase,
the steady increase of
carbon dioxide, which
will change the climate.
It may melt the ice sheet.
We don't know much about it, but
coastal cities may disappear.
I saw a map the other day
of what could have happened,
which Florida is
gone, Holland is gone,
the whole coastal east is gone.
They don't care about this.
Then they have the
chemical pollution,
the atmosphere is
threatened, threatens animals
and vegetation.
The acid rain,
and other things--
the death of the forests,
which in Europe is
a major catastrophe
and probably will
come to this country and the
Soviet Union pretty soon.
We have so far protected because
our population density is not
as high.
Now here are things that need
scientific investigation, that
need scientific collaboration,
that need big projects.
But where are our
scientists, they
go into defense,
what we call defense.
They go into all this
weapons development
and the financial
support goes there,
whereas there are
many other dangers.
And I've only mentioned two.
There are many more--
pollution of the
oceans, overpopulation,
over-exploitation of soil,
famine, et cetera, et cetera.
So all these dangers
threaten both superpowers.
And here's a
wonderful opportunity
for cooperation, which will
reduce fear and distrust.
Now and even the transfer
of scientific and technical
interests to other aims
and weapon [INAUDIBLE]
would even help to counteract
the self-propelling momentum
of the armaments effort.
Maybe I'm too optimistic,
but one should try.
So there are, of course--
there is, of course--
well, then commerce.
We should have much
more in commerces,
so that we are sort of
interdependent of each other.
That is a help and not a danger,
as it is often described.
Europe is a little ahead of us.
They have the gas line
from Soviet Russia.
They live a much more--
they have much more commerce
with the Soviet Union,
et cetera.
But of course, one
of the main obstacles
is always the question
of human rights.
How can you collaborate
with a system that
treats its citizens that way?
But I think that's just
the other way around.
It is bad that they
treat their citizens,
but you must fight it,
and you must tell it,
and you must talk about it.
But by not having any
collaboration and cooperation
with them, we make things
only worse, as we do.
Since the so-called detente.
Detente, unfortunately,
is a bad word now.
But it's a lessening of tension.
It's just what we want.
Now, since the last detente,
since detente has stopped,
only there are even more
persecutions, and more bad
things, more restrictions
of civil and human rights
in the Soviet Union.
So to be in touch with them,
to be able to talk directly
to them, and they're
coming here and looking
at the way we live, is, of
course, much more important.
We should not hope that
we can change the system.
The last opportunity to change
a despicable political system
by force was the
Second World War.
And it was pretty expensive.
From now on, we just can't do
it if that system is a big power
and has nuclear weapons.
So the only hope of changing
what happens in Russia
is a slow improvement,
which would probably
take a long time.
But it can only happen if fear,
confrontation, and distrust
subsides.
And let's see, technocrats
come to power, and who don't--
for whom ideological questions
are of no importance.
These are the lessons
which we should
draw from the sad experience
of the past 40 years,
when our great hopes 40
years ago for a better
world without conflicts
were temporarily dashed.
There's still hope for
hope for the next 40 years.
The threat of nuclear war
has kept an uneasy peace.
It has given us time.
There is a meta
stable situation.
But it's only a meta stable.
It will not last forever.
So we have still time
to learn the lesson,
to change the present course,
which in the long run,
is a collision course.
But this will require the
collaboration of all of you,
in particular the young people.
Because it's the young people
who will decide what happens.
And if they do not participate
actively in this fight,
by talking, discussing,
writing to congressmen,
and trying to influence
colleagues, et cetera,
we will not get very far.
It will require political
and military insight,
and an understanding of the
psychology of the adversary,
and a great deal of wisdom, and
the readiness to compromise,
none of which was
much in evidence
during the last 40 years.
But progress must be based, and
all what you do must be based
on an absolute
pragmatic, ethical,
and moral dedication to the aim
that nuclear war should not,
cannot, and must not occur.
My colleagues and I
constructed the atomic bomb.
If we hadn't, other people would
have done it sooner or later.
What nature has made
possible cannot be avoided.
But the lessons we draw from
it, and what we do with it,
that depends on
us, not on nature.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: Thank you, Viki.
The next speaker is
Professor Philip Morrison.
Phillip--
[APPLAUSE]
MORRISON: Thank you.
I'm afraid that among the
pleasures of such discussion
we miss the chance for
sharp disagreement, which
always bring some learning.
We'll have to forego that,
because we are somehow
too similar in point of view.
I shall try not to repeat
any of the wise remarks,
but to fit carefully in
between them with footnotes.
We'll see how that scheme works.
I too could begin
with a memo that
came across my desk
just yesterday,
literally, in the mail.
It was something which I
myself wrote 40 years ago.
It was the quasi
official and rather
over formal,
careful presentation
of my experiences at the Trinity
site on July 16, morning,
1945, which was stuck in
the files of the Los Alamos
laboratory all these years.
And some author has dug them
out, along with many others.
And he thought
I'd be interested.
And I was, of course,
interested to see it again.
I remember the main point, which
is the first paragraph which
I begin.
It's the same memory
that Viki has.
[INAUDIBLE] at base camp.
At 18,000 yards, 10 miles, must
have had the same experience.
The site was awesome.
The sound was extraordinarily.
We were prepared for that.
What I was somehow
not prepared for,
by the calculations
and discussions
we had had, was the sense
of warmth on the face,
as hot as summer moon,
just for a fraction
of a second or a second.
And coming in the cold desert
morning, well before dawn,
this is an extraordinary
experience, indelible.
Because, of course, that
kind of sensory input,
with such an live
channel of input,
is something that you
remember beyond the vision,
beyond the sound, beyond
the rational and awesome
consequences that we could draw.
Two of my old colleagues
at Los Alamos, one of whom
I think is in this room,
have been much impressed
by this same memory.
And have repeatedly written and
spoken, at least tentatively,
concerning the possible
wisdom of having
an occasional ceremonial
above-ground test
of a nuclear device,
somewhere in the desert
or the broad Pacific, to which
we invited the heads of state
or the representatives, so
they too might be at base camp,
10 miles away, and feel
the heat on the face.
This may be a very
ingenuous view of how
statesmen minds are changed.
But it is not without it's--
not without its persuasiveness.
And I hope to hear more
about that as time goes on.
Now I'd like to put the
whole thing into a little bit
more history, as usual
by case studies, which
is the way I deal with history.
And I would like to
tell you something
which I fell into by
the persuasiveness
of another colleague, Professor
Zacharias, who is here.
Some years ago, maybe
a decade ago or more,
I was caused by his
persuasion to go to Oklahoma
City, a place I rarely visit.
[LAUGHTER]
But in Oklahoma City,
I met a remarkable man.
It was his birthday.
He was a leader
of the community.
I shan't describe
all his virtues.
But he was a man who was then
celebrating his 100th birthday.
One doesn't get a chance
to meet articulate people
with that kind of extensive
historical experience.
And we sat in each
other at lunch.
And since I was a physicist,
and he was interested in that,
he told me the following
remarkable story.
Which begins, in my view,
it was the beginning
of the 20th century in physics.
Physicists never get
things quite straight.
So for us the 20th
century begins in 1896.
Now, in January 1896, this
man was a young student
in the freshman physics
course at Colorado College.
And he was professor
came in that morning,
having seen the paper, and said,
the Rockaway News is coming,
the newspaper.
Today.
I'm going to cancel the
lecture I was planning,
and the work that you're
supposed to do, I urge you--
I invite you to work
with me this morning.
And together, if
all of us work hard,
we'll be able to do
something quite wonderful.
Because a German professor,
far off in [INAUDIBLE]
Professor Rankin
has today published
how to make ras that will
allow him to take photographs
of the bones in the living
hand, right through the flesh.
You can see the skeletal shape.
And his equipment
is straightforward.
He describes it-- we have
that same equipment here
in our shop.
If we work hard,
I think by the end
of the morning we'll have
accomplished this fact.
Perhaps, we'll be the first
in the entire United States
to do so.
So indeed they fell
to with a will.
And my 100-year-old
acquaintance remembered
going to the last
moment, to the chapel,
to fetch a big
thick Bible, so they
could take a photograph of
a key through a book, which
is the other great
demonstration of the X-rays.
And indeed, it worked
just as they said.
And they were very
happy and contented.
The morning was well spent.
It took them in Colorado,
thousands of miles
from the centers for research,
it took them a mere few hours
to duplicate this
remarkable discovery.
They were not the first.
And not the first for a
simple geographical reason.
In Colorado, not because of
the indolence of the people,
but because of the
roundness of the Earth.
The sun rises two
hours later that it
rises in New York, Boston,
Philadelphia, and so on.
Because it's on Mountain time.
And therefore,
when they were just
assembling, when hearing
the professor's news
to the newspaper, the New
York, Boston, Philadelphia, New
England, their [INAUDIBLE] had
already been at work two hours.
And indeed, all across
the United States,
perhaps in half
a dozen colleges,
in a rather provincial country,
from the point of physics
research in 1896, the
X-rays had been duplicated.
There's no question that
this discovery this was
in the medium, and it simply
required crystallization
to make it appear.
The nucleus was all
you had to drop in.
Now, exactly the
same situation--
I only realized in the
last couple of months,
preparing lectures
for our course--
exactly the same situation
applied to the discovery
of nuclear fission.
When fission was
described correctly
by Meitner and
[INAUDIBLE] in terms
that they worked out in
Christmas vacation in 1938,
and was announced to the
world, across the world,
from Japan, to the Soviet Union,
every place where there was
a halfway respectable department
of physics with nuclear physics
interests, was able to
duplicate the effect right away.
And in a couple of day,
showed the fission pulses
on an oscilloscope to
anybody who would ask.
Pulses 50 times more intense
than the pulses from alpha
particle emission, which
was quite common to see
in the same display.
So you see, this is the
example of two cases--
I know of no others
really like that--
two cases where fundamental
change occurred, in a sense,
long overdue.
The community was ready for it.
The instruments had
been used widely
and developed for the purpose.
The [INAUDIBLE] was
available everywhere.
The photographic plate
was available everywhere.
There was no problem.
Just the right combination
had not been found.
And once that
combination was given,
the box was unlocked
all over the world.
And the same thing
happened with fission.
Many people failed to discover
fission in the three years
before it was discovered.
By this or that
small failure, it
was just chance led them to put
an extra piece of scotch tape
across the sample.
That's an actual case.
Not to be able to turn
the knob far enough
and the design spectrograph
to catch the energy
of the next X-ray line.
A number of other
events like that,
which prevented the
premature, so to speak,
discovery of fission.
So that in a way-- and this
is again what Viki said--
the matter has the property of
the release, the large scale
release of nuclear energy.
And it came to us as a
extraordinary discovery.
But it came, of course,
in a different context.
It was not 1896, but early 1939.
World War began in late 1939.
And was sealed,
most people feel,
by the Munich events
of the fall of 1938.
This we felt all over, and
in California, where I was.
Within a month, after we
first heard of fission, I,
myself, remember--
and I was no expert,
and didn't understand,
except for the most elementary
way, the nature of neutron
diffusion.
Drew on the board in [INAUDIBLE]
219, which we graduate students
shared in the [INAUDIBLE]
room of Robert Oppenheimer,
a drawing of a nuclear weapon,
with the key words-- deuterium,
and chain, and all those
things that you might now
associate with it.
It was very naive.
Would not have worked.
But was not the result
of serious effort.
It was just what was in the air.
It was the climate of opinion.
And so it seems very difficult
to avoid the conclusion
that we were in for, one way or
another, to face this problem.
What did happen,
as a consequence
of this strange chance,
was the close coincidence
between the opening of this
possibility and the outbreak
of the war, stimulated
by the most virulent,
self-declared, aggressive
regime in the history of Europe
for centuries.
This was a piece,
perhaps, of bad luck.
Total war was implied by
the headlines of the events.
And here was the device,
embryonic device,
suited intrinsically to
that particular activity.
And that, perhaps, is
the historical tragedy,
which we could not
have controlled,
but which we certainly
have to recognize.
Now, the institutions that
are responsible for this
are the most dominant
institutions in our lives.
They have been so
for 300 years, about.
That's not as old as
modern science, which
goes back now about 400 years.
But these three
or four centuries
have seen the
simultaneous growth
of the two most
important institutions
of contemporary life.
I think it's plain
what they are.
They are nations, national
states, on the one hand,
and science and its conscious
application technology,
both ways, on the other hand.
These two institutions represent
the modern world in many ways.
And if you look at the pages
of the books, of history,
you'll see them on
every page, increasingly
strongly as the
centuries have come by.
They have very different ideals.
They have very
different origins.
One speaks for
diversity, universality.
The other speaks for
adherence, coherence, pride
in limited community.
True, [INAUDIBLE]
specialization has
lost some of its
universality, specialization,
both in place and in nature.
But, of course, the national
state has, in fact, perhaps
has become somewhat larger.
But still, is primarily
much in the form
that the revolutionaries
of France,
or the United States,
for that matter,
would have recognized as
the formation of a nation.
And nation building
and nation forming
has never been more
vigorous than it
has been since the
energy released first
after World War I, when
the great empires of Europe
crashed, and then World War
II, when the great empires that
held colonial sway
across the countries
also crashed in their turn--
Holland, the British
Commonwealth, and so on.
Now, in the days
of the enlightened,
it's hard to believe how
these two institutions fitted
with each other.
And it's very difficult
to satisfy yourself
that it's the same way,
from the present day,
that it's that way.
But it was that way.
And there are many reasons.
I shan't elaborate that much.
You can see them for yourselves.
But I just wanted
to mention two.
When Captain Cook set sail
on his wonderful expedition
to explore the-- to look
for a Southern continent,
measure the transit
of Venus, and explore
the Pacific for His
Majesty, our country,
which was at war with Great
Britain, a Revolutionary
War in full energy, through its
brilliant scientific ambassador
to Paris, Mr. Franklin, wrote
a letter to all our commanders
at sea, saying, by no means
attack Captain Cook's vessel.
Give him free passage.
He sails not as a
British ship, not as
a ship of the British Navy, but
as a representative of science.
What he does will only
enhance the virtues
to all mankind, including
the United States of America,
and gave him safe conduct.
It's hard to believe
that would happen today.
Even later, even later when
Colonel William Lambton was
engaged by the East
India Company, not even
the British state, but
an agent of the state,
the East India Company, to begin
the great triangulation, which
has led to the
modern Indian survey,
beautifully mapped from
Himalayas to the Cape,
his great fundamental
theodolite that
was to be used to establish
the principle geodetic
coordinates, was sent by sea
and captured by a French ship--
a disaster.
No.
Three or four years
later, no great delay
in the circumstances of
1808 or 1810, when it was,
it appeared, by courtesy
of the French Academy, who
said they had no interest
in depriving Colonel Lambon
of his wonderful instrument.
And there was.
Please use it and
publish the maps.
Well, it was a time you
may say was ingenuous.
Of course, it was a time when
science did not have the power,
did not generate the power yet.
The power was, of
course, in the hands
of armorers, always had been.
But it was technology,
and not yet much
influenced by the more
rational abstract qualities
that we see in
post-Galilean science.
Nowadays, of course,
the figure of the earth
is a top military secret.
And if you know where
there are concentrations
of mass and changes in
the geode that haven't yet
been worked out from the
satellite perturbations,
you better not tell
anybody, because it's
very important for
directing the missiles.
And against it is
this exponential rise
of a powerful means
of understanding,
and thus controlling,
features the environment.
These two great
changes interlock.
And something new entered
with nuclear weapons,
which I maintain are special.
It's a dangerous
position to maintain,
but I think it is a real one.
It is verifiable in some
sense quantitatively.
They are not ordinary.
People have always wondered
at the expressions of energy.
And of course, in terms
of sheer total energy,
we still can't match the
energy released in nature.
The philosophers of Hellenic
and Hellenistic times
recognized energy and
gravitation, falling bodies,
in the winds, in
the water currents,
the waves of the ocean.
Of course, they don't have
the power density which we
command in nuclear explosions.
They recognized a
second kind of energy,
animate energy, the
energy characteristic
of human beings,
their own motion,
and the motion of
all the animals.
In fact that sign
of motion, we still
speak of something
animated when it is moving.
And the notion that mechanical
objects would also move
came as a strange
and marvelous thing.
2,000 years ago, and even
five 300 or 400 years ago,
it was still quite
remarkable, that motion
could be transferred from
living things or mere forces
of nature, where it
was intrinsic to move
like wind and waves, to
little clockwork objects.
We've lost that
sense entirely today.
So I think I said earlier,
in this very room,
there's a parallel
today, which has
to do with intelligence
in mechanical objects.
And there too, people are
puzzled and associated.
I think it's very likely the
same consequences to occur.
Namely, it will be
transferred to mechanisms.
And we won't understand
those mechanisms.
Those mechanism will not enable
us to understand intelligence
in ourselves, any more than
the motion of windup mice
enable us to understand
mice very well.
It's a very small
part of the problem.
But the power in
nuclear explosives,
as everyone's pointed
out, is extraordinary.
But this is the
fundamental point.
The fundamental point
is not only the power
that can be summoned there.
Of course, if you
pile up enough TNT,
you can pile up the
same amount of energy.
But you can't do that.
You can't do that economically.
It is the
extraordinary cheapness
of nuclear energy
in explosive form
that is the characteristic
danger of the situation.
It must be 20 years ago, I
was riding in an airplane one
night, late flight.
And I had bought a copy of
a familiar magazine, The New
Yorker, looking at the cartoons.
I was startled to
find a cartoon which
was based on the following
conceit of a clever cartoonist.
Was a time Soviet-Chinese
differences, in the early '60s.
And the cartoon showed
a gentleman, [INAUDIBLE]
of the Chinese, a Mandarin--
one of the Mandarin [INAUDIBLE]
learned Mandarin [INAUDIBLE],,
impassive in his robes,
and waving the appropriate fan.
It's all made very chinoiserie.
And then a bunch of toiling
people in their blue uniforms--
you could see that--
making a great firecracker.
And the caption said,
they test, we test.
And that was the idea
of the cartoonist.
Now, the firecracker
was gigantic.
It was about as big as a house,
35 or 40 feet in diameter,
and it was drawn perhaps
150, 200 feet long.
And toiling men were carrying
a great thing to light it.
You can see the exaggeration
of the cartoonist.
But you recognize
that if I were to try
to make a megaton of gunpowder,
which must be what they used
of firecrackers, the
firecracker to represent that
would have to be a 30
foot diameter tube.
It would not just be 200 feet
long, or 2,000 feet long,
or two miles long,
or 20 miles long.
It would actually go
right across the horizon.
Add a few megatons, and
disappear into space,
like the Great Wall,
narrowing down to [INAUDIBLE]..
It's hyperbolic.
The cartoonist is
a better artist.
He knew if he drew that, people
would think it was impossible,
but it's simple sense.
And that's the
trouble, and very hard
to imagine that trouble if you
can't calculate it and face it.
And even when you've seen
it, it's not easy to imagine.
But that the situation.
As everyone knows, the
statistic-- a freight
train loaded with boxcars
of TNT, if it rattles by,
it will carry a megaton by
at full speed part your grade
crossing in eight hours.
That's a megaton.
The disposition of the
forces now gives each side
a yield of between 5 and 10
Geiger tons, 5,000 or 10,000
megatons each side.
This is inordinate.
It doesn't compare to any
of the other structures
in our society.
And that's why I think it is
fair to say that it represents
a novel danger, not to be
compared to the terrible
history of war between nations,
which indeed is bad enough,
and in human terms cannot
be dismissed or diminished.
Who is to think otherwise, when
to read all these grave things.
Even though at the
same time, they
brought out courage,
and sacrifice, and unity
in the usual way that
nationalism has built for us.
Who could not hope
for an end to war?
Who would not dream of
[INAUDIBLE] of all time?
Ever since we've had states--
it's not intrinsic
probably to human beings--
but to the
organization in states.
But I think we have--
at the moment, I offer
a more modest goal.
It is the abolition of nuclear.
Which is not the same thing
as the abolition of war,
or the settlement of all
national differences,
or indeed, the common
agreement, which
we must try to seek and widen.
But I recognize that's an
old and longstanding problem.
And short of accomplishment
of just distribution
of the economic
goods of the world,
it seems to be very hard,
at least, to guarantee it.
And short of solving
the long histories which
imply the words of revenge,
and retribution, and so on,
the classic arguments
of the past,
I don't see how we can hope
to bring those to clear end.
But we can, I think,
separate out the idea
that nuclear war will not
serve any of these interests.
Nuclear war will not advance
the concerns of nations.
And it's only use, if it has
any use at all in the arsenals,
is as a deterrent against
nuclear war itself.
That's to say, as a hedge
against the fear that
surreptitious weapons could
be found, could be made,
which would represent a
violation of agreement,
and thus, bring danger.
And if you hold a small
threshold, a small amount,
which is enough to cover any
plausible concealment, then
indeed, that too
brings no advantage.
And could be expected to be
irrational and not much worried
about.
So that I think is the
end we have to look at,
the proximate end.
I don't deny, and I
would hope that we
can do much better than that.
But that is far enough.
It's much farther
than where we are now.
Because where we
are now, of course,
is a very clear position.
The statesmen have
by their action,
rather by their
inaction, in spite
of many provocations,
and many differences,
have refrained from
direct confrontation
between adversaries heavily
armed with nuclear weapons.
And that's because there is a
strong inhibition to their use,
a strong sense of
survival, and this
we can count all to the good.
But what they have
intended to say
is there will only be
no disaster on my watch.
Therefore, we'll build more
missiles, but not use them.
And the next group can decide
how to solve the matter.
That's been going
on for 40 years.
The justifications for
this system and that system
are so thin and so
self-contradictory,
as you read them over the
years, that we're just
doing the study
now in our course,
and it comes ever
clearer that there
is no way on the level
of individual decisions
to say that they
are right or wrong.
They're never very right.
They're always
tendentiously argued.
The essential
point appears to be
that states will spend
what they can spend,
5% or 10% of the gross
national product,
on military affairs,
whatever that
buys when they're
[INAUDIBLE] a state
of adversarial relationship.
Whatever that buys.
They don't ask what it buys,
they ask what can they spend.
It's the level of
effort that counts.
We have two million
men in armed services.
We've always had two million
men in the armed services,
since 1950.
And that's what it is.
And they can be armed.
However powerfully
they're armed,
it doesn't really matter, as
long as the expenditures are
about the same.
When we had 100s
or 1,000 bombers
flying three tons of bombs
each, or whether we have 1,000--
300 in this case, bombers,
and another 1,000 missiles,
with the equivalent of
a million tons each,
it really doesn't matter.
The cost is much the same.
And it's that which is
looked at by the states
and by their
[INAUDIBLE] And there's
no other explanation for
the order of magnitude
of what we've built up.
It's not measured
in terms of targets.
It's measured on
the input you need.
The input you need
is so and so much.
That's reasonable.
We always spent
that kind of sum.
Let's spend it again.
And it doesn't matter the
technicians are making
it easier to have the damage.
That's the tragedy.
It's not looked at in terms of
output, but in terms of input
alone.
Other technologies
will come along,
which will again engage this
conflict between technology
and the nation state.
I don't know which ones, but I'm
confident that the one we see
is sufficiently grave so
that we have to take action.
A new point has arisen.
It's not new, again, it's
a repetition of events,
as Viki said, of
1969 to 1972 or '73,
when the idea of a defense
against the delivery
of nuclear weapons was
in the air, literally.
And now, it's gone from
the air to outer space
for two of the three layers,
but still much the same thing.
And the trouble
with it, of course,
is not the detail of
the systems, not at all.
I don't want to discuss
X-ray lasers, or ground
based chemical lasers, or
whatever you have in mind.
Those are all interesting
and important discussions.
We should have them here.
But they don't-- in
this institution--
they don't represent
the real issue.
Because the real
issue is not that.
The real issue is that a defense
system, genuine defense--
that is active defense,
not deterrence,
nuclear weapons style--
has always been and remains
based upon marginal superiority
of an installed system.
My sword will
pierce your shield.
Not every time, you're
not shield-less,
but the decision has
always been in the margin.
Some little difference
has made a difference.
The shells penetrated the deck
of one side, but not the other.
And the remaining ships that
floated were of one kind.
They won the battle.
It's always in this
marginal distinction
that every defense,
offense war has been won.
And that will be true for
strategic defense initiatives,
in space, anywhere.
The general picture
is not the medium
that makes the difference.
It's the energy
and technical means
placed at the
disposal of those who
will counter any given system.
So we can expect, since
we've always seen it before,
a seesaw jockeying, which
now this will be hit,
now that will be hit.
And on top of that,
always the proposition
that nuclear weapons are
still inordinately powerful,
and a small leakage of
them through any defense
is devastating.
So you really, as everyone
said, raised another race.
But you've not solved
the fundamental problem.
The difference, again, is
this extraordinary order
of magnitude that
nuclear energy introduces
that none of the other
devices introduce at all.
Because they always
have their match.
But not nuclear energy,
there's no match.
I'm afraid that just as
we've seen with the B52,
which has only been used in
combat against a non-nuclear
power--
three of them-- Cambodia,
Laos, and Vietnam,
and the MX missile,
which was built
for quite a different
purpose than its present use,
to close the window
of vulnerability,
and skitter around the
Southwestern desert,
to avoid its targetability,
imitating the submarines,
abandoned.
No such justification
is present any longer.
It's just meant as a better
missile with a hard target kill
capability, to add
to our present force.
And so I believe, in fact, that
the SDI system, when it finally
is built, and has
its terminal defense
and a few things
in orbit and so on,
will not at all be
regarded as adequate
against the powerful
countermeasures and increased
missile powers of the powerful
superpower against us,
but will be used on the
side to threaten and perhaps
even to strike at
somebody somewhere else
in the world, who hasn't got any
kind of anti-missile capability
or satellites or anything else.
Because against such a power,
it is indeed a powerful weapon,
not perhaps a winning weapon,
though very powerful activity,
just as the 52s were very--
dropped a lot of bombs
through the monsoon
are Laos and Cambodia.
Whether they won anything,
it's hard to say,
but they certainly blew
up a lot of territory.
And I'm afraid that's
what we're going to see.
Missile systems have
this curious life,
or systems have
this curious life.
Once built, their
utility depends on what
you choose to do with them.
And when they're
badly conceived,
then they're not useful
for the primary purpose.
And they are so expensive,
you couldn't build them
for the secondary purpose.
But you've got them.
So there they are.
I think that's the situation.
And I believe the solution has
got to be measures of restraint
as an initial break
to the situation.
Restraint, not just negotiated,
long negotiated mutuality.
Rapidly produced measures
of unilateral restraint,
using that word.
And I say this, I
wanted to say it,
but I got a letter today,
which I'll just comment on,
a form letter, of course, from
a very able Congresswoman,
Patricia Schroeder, of the
Armed Services Committee,
a Congresswoman from Colorado.
And she proposes the
following scheme.
Now, I have no way--
I haven't talked
to enough people
to say this is a good
idea or a bad idea.
It appeals to me very much.
I'm sure it is the flavor of
what eventually will work.
And I put it forward to
you only and that means.
It depends upon timing.
It depends upon unity.
It depends on political
circumstances.
Maybe none of these
are propitious.
But the idea is a sound one.
I'll just mention it.
She says, let it be the sense
of Congress that on August 6--
before August 6,
1985, our president
shall announce a three
month withholding
of all nuclear
tests on condition
only that the Russians
do the same thing.
And if they do, if
he does not certify
that they have made a
test, then the Congress
will not allow any
money to be spent
on this for such
purposes, indefinitely,
looking at it every
six months or a year.
Meanwhile, negotiations
begin on a more
formidable and comprehensive
test [INAUDIBLE]..
I think this is interesting.
Very mild restraint,
because you're not
going to lose very much
under any circumstance.
It's verifiable.
And it has the quality
of an initiative, which
is what we need,
something to start with,
not waiting to see whether the
bargaining chips on the table
can be counted up well.
So unless we find such
initiatives of restraint,
unless we find such
minor sacrifices,
minor risks to take in the face
of this growing, steady, never
decisive, but always
terrible risk, which
is the single minded
arms race for greater
and greater destruction, then
I think we'll find no way out.
And I believe one
side or the other
must try this, once,
twice, many times,
until it becomes [INAUDIBLE].
Always careful not to
compromise the peace
in any substantial
way, by the small,
but clearly indicated
direction of its proposals.
So I close then, very
much in the same way
that I would have
closed the talk in 1945,
showing that one doesn't
learn very much in this world.
But when we came back
from New Mexico and Japan,
the scientists, ingenuous,
but energetic, as usual,
made up slogans for what should
be done in the crisis of 1945.
And I think the
slogans are not bad.
And I'd like to repeat
them again in this time,
with a little
explanation and end.
First of all, we said there
is no secret to this thing.
That's a foregone
conclusion now.
Nobody imagines there is.
It's all over the world.
But of course, in those days, it
was a big political statement,
because the notion was
we would hold the secret
and we alone, with the UK, would
be the sole nuclear powers.
We said that will not work.
The secret will fade.
The secret is held in
the uranium nucleus,
and that is everywhere.
Second, we said there
will be no defense,
not because we knew about
X-ray lasers, we didn't.
Because we knew the simple
argument I made before,
that defense is in the
margin, but nuclear weapons
are beyond that.
And finally, we said
that it seems there's
only one way to proceed.
And that is, somehow by
eventual international agreement
to do away, as far as we
can, with nuclear war.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: Phil and Viki, thank
you for incredible talks.
Mr. Bajpai would you honor
us with some remarks?
Mr. Bajpai is the
Indian ambassador.
[APPLAUSE]
BAJPAI: Provost
Low and friends, I
find myself in
double embarrassment
that almost everything I
would have liked to say
has been so much better
said, not only by these two
greats because we have just
heard, but more briefly,
but very much to the point
also, in the collection that you
have in the pamphlet
that is with you.
My other embarrassment
is, quite candidly,
that I look like being suspect
of joining dangerous company,
because we all
feel the same way.
And the way they
feel is not very
popular in certain quarters.
And I rather fear
that we may all
be accused of conspiring
together to corrupt the young.
[LAUGHTER]
And to subvert the international
system, as the powers that are
prefer to see it.
And subvert the existing
or accepted prevailing
wisdom, in Washington at least.
I must confess that the
presence of a layman like myself
in this very remarkable
gathering of scientists
must raise two questions, at
least in my mind, if not yours,
is why I was included, and
the other is why I came.
The first I would--
I'm sure is not because
the father of the atom bomb
quoted one of our
scriptures when the atom
bomb was first exploded.
And I hope it is not
just because India
is one of the countries in
the world that has developed
the know how of nuclear energy.
I wish I could think it was
an acknowledgment of India's
commitment to this cause
of finding solutions
to this terrible
fear that we have all
lived under in these 40 years.
It is a remarkable coincidence,
in a way, that this nuclear age
is almost--
at the same time, began at
the same time, as India's life
as a modern state.
It was a day of dread
and glory for all of us.
And the tragedy of those of us
who come from the developing
world is that the glory we
had hoped to achieve from it
has yet to manifest itself.
And the dread is
all too pervasive.
I, of course, have come
because we continue
to attach this very
high importance,
and have from the very beginning
of our life as a member
of the international
community, tried
to work for a solution,
which after a very few years,
we came to believe [INAUDIBLE]
complete and general
disarmament, starting
with the total abolition
of all nuclear weapons.
We have been pressing
for this since we first
launched the proposal in
the United Nations in 1954.
And followed it up with other
proposals about banning tests,
about stopping vertical, as well
as horizontal, proliferation.
And indeed, about outlying
nuclear weapons altogether.
We haven't gotten
very far, as you know.
And there's yet
another anniversary
that we will be
observing this year.
It is the 10th anniversary of
the non-proliferation treaty.
And many have said,
all right, if you
can't manage the totality
of the danger, at least
let us limit it by going
through the self-denial process
of those countries that have
not yet developed the bomb.
We have not signed the
Nonproliferation Treaty,
although we have advocated
its purposes and intentions.
And I think that is
because of a factor that
has been mentioned in passing
or indirectly earlier today.
The nation state has probably
been responsible for more wars
than almost any other
single factor in history.
And yet, we, who
became nation states,
only a few years
ago, are much too
jealous and proud of that
fact to want a different order
of international affairs.
But what we have always
wanted is a different order
of international behavior.
I don't know how many of you
saw the film this afternoon,
but one of those who
was interviewed in it
had an interesting
recollection that the capacity
to produce this weapon really
came to fruition after Germany
had already surrendered.
And I believe you all had a
debate as to whether to go
ahead or not.
And as I think--
who was it that was
recollecting this?
Professor Wilson-- he
mentioned that talking
to Dr. Oppenheimer, they
argued back and forth.
And Oppenheimer
said, no, this is
the age of the United Nations.
And the United Nations
is going to usher
in a new world order
which must know
what this dreadful power is.
I take it, therefore,
that the scientists
of that time, as I see know from
the scientists of today, did
have in mind a very
different way of nations
dealing with each other.
And if this implies some
surrender of sovereignty,
I am sure it would be acceptable
to nearly every country I can
think of, provided every
other country would do it
at the same time.
And that, of course, is what
nobody ever is prepared to do.
We have, therefore,
this continuing problem
of a few states wanting
to retain their monopoly
and telling the rest of us
that we should be good boys.
You'll pointed out,
Professor Weisskopf,
that the nuclear
powers have somehow
managed to keep the
peace between themselves
for 40 years, which is an
exceptionally long time.
I am reminded that an
almost equal span of time
prevailed between the Congress
of Vienna and the Crimea War.
And yet, during that period,
it was the smaller nations
who were denied their rights.
And the concert of
Europe, which ran
what was then called
the civilized world,
did manage to keep peace
between the powers that
formed that concert, but by
sowing the seeds for what
proved to be the
greatest wars of history.
I do not think we would like to
see that experience repeated.
So this so-called
balance of terror,
which is trying to keep the
world at peace through fear,
has now reached this
ridiculous proportion,
where you keep piling up.
And the scales maybe
perhaps able to maintain
that equilibrium.
But if you keep piling
up, the scales may break.
And then where will we be?
So those of us who had
looked for the peaceful uses
of nuclear development, and
which we hoped would enable us,
particularly coming from
a country like India,
with its vast potential,
but also its vast problems,
would help us give to our people
the type of life that you had
built for yourselves, cannot
help wonder whether it's worth
the effort, and whether we must
not now think of other ways
of achieving that.
As far as this is concerned,
we have persisted, as I say,
in pressing for total
abolition of nuclear weapons.
And in the process, we have
been told that we are naive.
The fact of life is that
a few countries have it
and they will manage.
And the rest of us, as
I said, better behave.
And others have gone so far
as to say that we are devious,
that while we maintain this
posture on the one hand,
we do not sign the
NPT on the other.
And that we are merely
allowing ourselves the option
to use the nuclear energy
for military purposes when
we want to.
I would on that, just mention
one word, that our record is
there for everyone to see.
We have demonstrated
a capability,
but not developed it.
And we do keep urging others
to follow our example.
The epithets that are used
used to be applied to a man
called Gandhi, whom the British
thought on the one hand naive
and on the other devious.
I think most, if not
all of us here today
would agree that looking back
on his life and his achievement,
he was able to do something very
new, which was to make people
behave in a different way.
Certainly, we in India,
somehow under his leadership,
rose to a level of loyalty
of devotion of self-denial,
which probably we
can never do again,
until another
Gandhi comes along.
But it did give us the hope
that the rest of mankind
can under competent leadership,
or inspiring leadership,
achieve that same
type of change.
And what we are
really thinking of
is to change men's
minds so that nations
can change their ways of
dealing with each other.
And we still believe
that that is possible.
We do not have a
Gandhi to offer you,
but you have so many people
who can speak that language,
perhaps we don't need him.
But I would like to say
that the type of ideas
that I've heard today
are so much what
we have tried to advocate.
It is very heartening to find
circles in the United States
that I can feel at
home in this matter.
But above all, I
would say I think
it was another great man of
science, Sir William Oslo, who
used to say, that in science,
it does not matter who
first conceives of
an idea, what matters
is who will convince the world.
I'm afraid we in India
have not found it
possible to convince the world.
I hope all of your scientists,
and above all, all of you
young people here
today, will succeed.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: Thank you for
your eloquent remarks.
I think we have time for
some comments and questions,
not too many.
Sir--
AUDIENCE: I was very happy
to hear he mention of Gandhi.
I'm very impressed
with the possibilities
of non-violence myself.
Most of the comments from the
speakers about what can be done
were dealt with on a
Congressional, or executive,
or policy levels, and I'm just
wondering if the distinguished
speakers here could
comment on what value
they see in
non-violent resistance
as a way of furthering ourselves
for the goal of [INAUDIBLE]
WEISSKOPF: Well, yes, I would
see a lot of possibilities.
You know, at the
end of my talk, I
said that it really
depends on all of us,
in particular on
the young people,
on the younger
generation, to establish
this change of attitude
towards our opponents, that
would make and would avoid
the terrible possibilities.
Now, this change of attitude,
how do you get at it?
By demonstrations,
by speaking out.
And this is a kind of
non-violent resistance.
I'm sure some people will
not like it, what I say,
but the kind of demonstrations
to prevent certain weapons,
well, they usually do not at
the end really prevent them,
but I think they have a very
important purpose of showing
the ideas that are in the
population, the resistance,
for example, in Europe
against the erection
of those intermediate arrange
things and similar thing.
In other words, although
it is in principle
against the law,
these demonstrations,
as long as they
are not violent, I
think they are one
of those expressions
that I think would help.
You cannot do it only that way.
You also have to convince,
you have to argue,
you have to get the
majority on your side.
But certainly nonviolent
demonstrations,
if I understand
that's what you mean--
AUDIENCE: Civil
disobedience-- do
you see a role for
civil disobedience?
WEISSKOPF: Yes,
in certain cases,
it may just be a
demonstration of the strength
of your convictions.
AUDIENCE: Something
that I thought
might be talked about this
evening, that I think perhaps
we should touch on a little
bit is the consideration
that weapons require builders.
And as we all know, MIT
is one of the places
where much of the building
of these weapons gets done.
Ideally, perhaps, decisions
about whether to build weapons
as political
decisions should not
have to concern
scientists and engineers.
But given the fact that the
government and our politicians
continue to be as irrational
as you two pointed out,
I think we are forced
to think about it.
And so I want to ask you, as
a student who may or may not
go into science,
especially in a world where
so much of the funding is
only available for defense
work, how should we
think about this problem,
and especially considering
the fact that we're at MIT?
And the title--
MORRISON: Of course,
it's not a new--
it's a difficult question,
but hardly a new one.
I'm afraid I take a very
social view of the situation.
I'm not against, but hardly
enthusiastic for solutions
that mean the thing goes
on just as well elsewhere.
Or the thing goes
on, but without me.
These are valuable
answers for individuals.
And I would never deny
any person that right.
It's indeed a
necessity to work out
for every individual,
the comfort, the degree
of opposition to the
national direction
that that person
wants to stand in.
But really, to move a laboratory
from one place to another,
or to do something
[INAUDIBLE] is
I think primarily an evasion,
unless it is used to organize
opinion in a broader sense.
So I'm not quite sure
that I'm speaking directly
to your point, but I
think what I'm seeking is,
how to deny the
power to the state,
to manufacture more
or less what it
wants to do, I think it's
very difficult for us,
unless a large majority
of people agree on it.
Then I think there's very little
chance of succeeding along
those lines.
And if they do agree,
the institutions still
exist to use the power of
the state to withhold it,
not to spend the money, not
to organize the factories,
to sign the treaties, and so on.
I feel this is a the direction
which the solution will lie.
That doesn't exclude
that everyone must
find a personal relationship.
WEISSKOPF: May I add something?
See MIT essentially
represents the United States.
I would even say it--
actually, there are
probably more people
against the present--
percent wise-- against
the present trend at MIT.
But in general, MIT
represents, and should
represent the nation.
Because if we at MIT exclude
every weapon work, then--
well, I'm now a little
repeating what he said.
Then we would be an ivory tower
who would have no influence.
So in some ways,
I would say, sure,
it's your own decision
whether you will
go into that work or this work.
But let me assure you, if you
want to become a scientist,
you do not do it in
order to earn money.
Of course, you will earn
more money in defense.
But the few examples
which I have given
have shown that there are
other very important tasks
for science.
You know the examples.
And I think, therefore,
we need scientists.
And we need even
intelligent scientists
in the weapons departments.
Because they can then have an
influence there, and say, look,
what you do here is nonsense.
Even weapon developments
that are stabilizing and not
destabilizing, like some of
these so-called smart, not
nuclear weapon.
So things it's not that easy.
But certainly, you should
not use this as a reason
not to go into
science, that science
is abused for nuclear war.
LOW: Also, just to keep
the record straight,
one should say, MIT does
not do weapons work.
At the Lincoln Lab, which is
a quite separate installation,
and therefore, historic
reasons, radar work is done.
But MIT, as a university here,
does not do weapons work.
In any case, it does
not do any secret work.
And once you leave
the domain of secrecy,
it's hard to know what is
a weapon and what is not.
But certainly, no weapons
are designed here.
I'll add another thing.
I think an individual has
to decide to be a pacifist
or not to be a pacifist.
That is to say, if you oppose
war, then it is logical for you
to oppose weapons work.
If not, then somebody
has to do that work.
So I think it's not
intrinsically immoral,
any more than war
itself is immoral,
and our societies
do engage in it.
So I think to give yourself
the luxury of saying
I'm not going to
indulge in weapons work,
and then no community I
have anything to do with
should be involved in it, is
not, at least not consistent,
unless you're a pacifist.
AUDIENCE: To continue the point
that Scott Zaleski just made,
I think the question that I've
heard from a number of students
is whether--
let me back up and say, I
think that all three responses
suggest, and I
think quite rightly,
there's an issue of some
personal moral responsibility
and judgment as
to what one can do
who wants to go into science.
But I think that those of us
who are members of the faculty
and administration
at MIT perhaps or are
being told by the
[INAUDIBLE] that it's
a little lonely out there.
You're a young person.
You're facing
choices in which you
begin to discover that much
of what is interesting--
regarded as interesting
and exciting, much of what
is regarded as well-paid is
[INAUDIBLE] only by making
choices [INAUDIBLE] whether it's
done at MIT, or by extension
MIT graduates.
And I guess the follow-on
to Scott Zaleski's question
that I would like to
ask is, are there things
that an institution such
as this could and should
do to encourage the development
of alternative pathways
of career choices, so
those in large numbers,
of our students, who would if
they could make choices not
to do weapons
research, but perhaps
to work more actively
on the sorts of things
that Viki mentioned in
his quite reasonable list.
I'm trying to suggest that maybe
it's a little unfair for us
to reduce the whole matter to
a question of personal choice.
There are institutional
priorities [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: Steve, I agree with that.
And, in fact, the Institution
is moving in those directions.
There are people
in this Institution
who are hard at work on exactly
the kinds of questions--
kinds of movement that
Viki and Phil describe.
You know them.
They're here on the faculty.
And we are making every
effort to support them
and to expand that work.
And we hope it will bear fruit.
And we hope that there
will be new ideas.
And that students and members of
the community will be involved.
We're doing it.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, may
I get your attention?
I think I have a sort of
somewhat appropriate remark
to make.
It's not really a
question, but it's
sort of more or less a
statement or a request.
This afternoon,
Professor Martin Deutsch
said that in 1945 the human
race was forced, so to speak,
into adulthood by the bomb.
It occurred to me
at that time, that
to reverse the direction
of this nuclear madness,
we, as individual
adults, will have
to band together and meet a
challenge at least as great
as that which threatened
the nation and the world
back during World War II.
And perhaps in that
regard, I wanted
to say that a small group of
students and staff here at MIT
have been organizing
some efforts to provide
additional information
to students
who are preparing to make
occupational decisions as they
finish up at MIT.
Our preliminary focus has
been to talk with students
who are considering
taking jobs with companies
whose principal work is on
nuclear weapons systems.
We want to continue
this work and extend it.
Among the goals we
have is, for example,
to provide an up to date and
comprehensive set of reference
materials to be located in the
MIT Career Placement Office,
so that students who use
the office in a job search
have access to a concise
and accurate alternative
view of the many large defense
contractors who currently
recruit and provide shiny,
new, attractive brochures
on themselves at the
placement office.
This is just short.
We need help.
We need help, fresh ideas,
blood, sweat, and tears
to make an impact
at the Institute.
Our small efforts this semester
have been very encouraging.
It turns out that there are
a lot of students who really
haven't thought, and don't have
resources available to them
with their many problem sets,
and with all the interviews
that they have to go through
in getting out of here,
they really haven't had any
resources available to them
to help them make more moral
or ethical choices about jobs.
So finally, this summer
will be an ideal time
to begin our planning for
the fall recruiting period.
If you're interested, any
of you, in getting involved,
we need people who
can read and write,
who like research, and have
good ideas and enthusiasm.
Please get in touch with me.
My name is Ken Finkelstein.
You can reach me by leaving a
note at the Graduate Physics
Office.
That's Ken Finkelstein, and
we're the Student Committee
on Career Choices.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LOW: I think we have
come to the end.
Oh, I'm sorry, did
you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, I
did have a question,
but it's a little bit on a
slightly different issue.
So if there's anybody
who still wanted
to talk about the
career thing, I
want to wait a couple seconds.
OK, well, if there's
not, I'll just go ahead.
And first of all, Mr.
Ambassador, please corrupt me.
I love it.
But in any case, it
was sort of a question
for Professor Morrison.
When you were talking in terms
of the nuclear and conventional
war differences and how we
might be able to adjust to the--
adjust to going back to a
conventional war situation,
I'm not quite sure
I got you right.
But is it your opinion
that it's in any way
realistic to assume that
a nation would cut back
on nuclear arms, cut back on
them and then sort of just
feel free dabbling in the
second rate stuff, so to speak?
And if that's not
the case, isn't there
perhaps something wrong or
something inadequate right
now with the entire concept
of a sovereign nation at all?
MORRISON: Well,
to the last point,
I think there probably is
quite a lot wrong with it.
But I'm not in--
I'm too old to engage
in the projection
of large historical changes.
They might come, but I don't
know when they'll come.
But I do find it not at
all difficult to see.
I mean, restraint is the
essence of contemporary war.
We've seen it.
We've fought a war in which
we were rather badly beaten.
But we very rarely--
even only considered
extending that war because
of the obvious fact
that if we extended
that war at the nuclear
direction and escalated it,
we would've lost more
than we would have gained.
And that option is available
at any point in any war.
I look forward to
the possibility
that that could happen, that
even the great states would
confront each other
in war, recognizing
that if they were to
open it to nuclear war,
they would lose something
more than the issues at stake.
We are happy that they
are not near neighbors.
They don't have-- it's
not a question of they
will take Washington tomorrow.
The only way in which the
United States is endangered
is through nuclear weapons--
the zone of the interior.
We've given up this great
geopolitical advantage
for the sake of waging strategic
war far away, which is not
a very sensible thing to do.
But that's another talk
that I won't give now.
LOW: But probably the
war, the total war
with unconditional
surrender is out.
That's finished.
Because that would
probably lead to nuclear.
MORRISON: Probably, yeah.
LOW: Yes, sir--
AUDIENCE: During
World War II, we
had the Manhattan Project,
which was a research
project, which people didn't
know what the results would be.
But if they were
successful, would
certainly, and in fact, we can
see from with our hindsight,
certainly change the nature
of warfare and world politics.
Today, in the United
States, we have
Star Wars, or the Strategic
Defense Initiative.
Depending on whether
you're for or against it,
use one name or the other.
Which again is, at the
moment, is a research program.
Which if it was successful,
in total defense, if you will,
would again change the nature
of warfare and world politics.
And it seems to me that
some of the arguments
for and against Star Wars
could have been applied back
during World War II for
the Manhattan Project.
Do you think that's valid?
What similarities and
differences do you see?
MORRISON: Well, it's an
extremely interesting,
logical argument.
And I certainly would like
to give you a large big red A
for debating merit.
I think it's extremely well put.
But as a matter of fact,
I think you're selling
this perpetual motion machine.
I don't agree-- I
don't disagree at all.
And if you would
explain to me how
it's going to make
nuclear weapons, what
is it-- impotent and
obsolete, I'll sign onto it.
It just won't.
And the reason it won't is--
excuse me, I'm going
to make a remark.
It's not even
logically coherent.
What it really meant to
say was, logically, it'll
make ballistic missiles
impotent and obsolete.
That's the most it can claim.
Maybe it'll add cruise missiles.
But I'll be darned if
I see how it's going
to work on submarine torpedoes.
It isn't just discussing
the right issue.
[APPLAUSE]
So I personally think
it's a bill of goods.
I mean, the difference between
that and the Manhattan Project
was that when somebody
was willing enough
to put in $10 million dollars
into it, in the OSRD, probably
Kohnert and Bush,
and then it went.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
made the chain reaction.
And after that, it
looked pretty clear.
Another $500 million,
and so it went.
Well, that's what
has to be done here.
By the way, the chips
are now much bigger
for much less delivery.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the emphasis here
on the arms races itself.
And, I guess I would
address this to both of you,
as to why you are addressing
such overwhelming importance
to the arms race.
If one takes the point
of view, and I think one
might, that the
risks of nuclear war
are relatively independent
of either the size
or potential characteristics
of the arsenal,
then it's likely that even
if we add another 25,000
warheads to the arsenal,
or [INAUDIBLE] about 50,000
warheads now, the radical
[INAUDIBLE] proposal,
my judgment would be that
the risks of nuclear war
would not be
materially different,
until you get to a very
reduced level, though.
And that, in fact, in
the foreseeable future,
the risk of nuclear war, we
have relatively much less
to do with the size and
[INAUDIBLE] of the arsenal
[INAUDIBLE] and much more to do
with the political conditions
that govern relations
between super powers
and between the super
powers and the third world.
And I'm curious how you would
both judge the risks of war,
the risk of nuclear war,
in terms of the arms race,
per se, how important
you think the arms
race is a conditioned risk.
And second, why [INAUDIBLE]
WEISSKOPF: Well, I'm sorry that
my talk wasn't good enough,
because that's what I--
that's what I thought I said.
I mean, the arms race,
I agree with you,
with some kind of exaggeration.
I would say, the arms
race is a symptom.
I mean, if two superpowers are
really capable of producing
and increasing armaments
that are 50 times larger
than complete destruction,
something is wrong.
I mean, this is the mental
disease I was talking about.
And what I was trying to say,
maybe not clearly enough,
was that you need a
change of attitude.
That the arms-- not only you
cannot turn out the arms race,
but you will get a stable
instead of meta stable
situation, because the arms
race is a meta stable situation.
Only if you change the
attitude towards our adversary
in both directions.
And if you mean
that, I fully agree.
And I thought I said it.
But maybe not clear enough.
MORRISON: Well, maybe there
is a difference between Viki
and me, because I
really don't think
I agree with what you say.
I really think it's not
the risk of war that
counts, but the expectation.
And the expectation
is very high,
even if the risk is small.
Because the damage is so great
if it occurs in the wrong way.
And it's against
this expectation
that I'm primarily acting.
I don't expect to
see an end to war.
It might be, as he
says, a total war
with unconditional
surrender demands,
but that's in the
political domain.
What I mean is war
with the maximum use
of the technical capabilities
of modern society.
I don't think that
we could stand that.
And I think that the only--
way to get around
it is to remove
the serious consequences,
as far as possible,
by reducing nuclear armaments,
and their triggerness,
their readiness, their
instability, their first strike
advantages, all
these issues that
have come up in the theology
of the nuclear doctrine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the size
of the arsenal and [INAUDIBLE]
confrontation
between super powers.
The question
whether super powers
will escalate toward a nuclear
war, [INAUDIBLE] The question
of whether or not
they will escalate,
which I gather you're saying
is possible without [INAUDIBLE]
MORRISON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
prospects of that [INAUDIBLE]
are relative as to the size
of [INAUDIBLE] the arsenal
and much more related to the
political conditions that
govern relations [INAUDIBLE]
and the political rules
of conduct that have
developed [INAUDIBLE]
MORRISON: I just
don't agree with that.
I think you're wrong.
I think that the concrete
circumstances, what
are called the
capabilities, are more
determining than
judgments of intentions
and rules of engagement.
That's characteristic
of most war.
And I think if you
cut this thing down--
I agree a factor of two won't
make a bit of difference
from my point of view.
But it only shows direction.
Therefore, any small
change is valuable now,
because it signals direction.
But if you cut it by
an order of magnitude,
which is what I'm
speaking of, then I
think it makes a big difference.
It no longer is decisive
in and of itself.
It no longer represents
anything but another gamble,
if you try to escalate now,
who will make the most weapons,
and who will do them first,
and who will end them best.
That's putting the whole
war on a certain gamble
of novel technology,
which is very hard to do,
which I don't anticipate
people would manage.
So I think that it is
possible, without increasing
the risk of major
superpower conflict,
to reduce the number of
weapons, and very greatly
reduce the instability
of the situation.
LOW: I'll take just
one more question.
I want to end at 10.
Yes, sir--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that there's
a moral distinction between
killing a million people
and killing 4 billion
people, [INAUDIBLE]
Conventional warfare's OK.
MORRISON: No.
I don't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MORRISON: No, but there's
a practical distinction
of great importance.
Namely important to
3,999,000,000 people,
if I take your numbers.
Look, we've seen 20
million people killed,
roughly speaking, in wars since
World War II, maybe only 15.
AUDIENCE: And there's nothing
wrong with [INAUDIBLE]
MORRISON: No, that's terrible.
But do you think
that the presence
of nuclear power,
superpower armaments
has made that less likely?
I think it's contributed
a great deal to it.
Client states everywhere have
been put to work warring,
because the big boys didn't want
them engage in it themselves.
I feel that's the
principal reason.
LOW: Thank you very much.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]